Eisenhower arrives in Bermuda for big three
talks to strengthen the alliance of the free world
British Prime Minister Winston Churchill just
turned 79 his on hand to greet the president with
foreign minister Anthony Eden and French premier
Joseph blan yell an air of friendliness and warmth
marks their first meeting a spirit that continues
throughout the crucial conference at the mid-ocean
Club site of the talks the trio emerges after
announcing agreement on a meeting of Russian and
Western foreign ministers a step perhaps toward
peace by a premier president and prime minister
flying to New York to address the UN General
Assembly President Eisenhower is greeted by
Secretary General Doug Hummer sealed inside the
hall madame pundit assembly president welcomes
mr. Eisenhower who presents a dramatic plan for
International pooling of atomic materials the
United States pledges before you and therefore
before the world its determination to help
solve the fearful atomic dilemma to devote its
entire heart and mind to find the way by which
the miraculous inventiveness of man shall not
be dedicated to his death but consecrated to
his life playing the Sultan of Morocco and
his arrival at Washington National Airport
President Eisenhower stands bareheaded in a
raw and whipping wind the lengthy ceremony is
completed the President and the Sultan ride in
an open car through the streets of the capital
though Ike gives no evidence of illness
within an hour he complains of a chill a
team of doctors is called and the president
is found to have suffered a mild stroke at
the White House dr. Howard Schneider Ike's
personal physician emphasizes that there is
no disability and four days later the
nation receives dramatic assurance of
the president's rapid recovery and she goes to
church with mrs. Eisenhower less than a month
after his illness he is in Paris attending
an unprecedented meeting of the NATO chief
sub government all soldier Dwight Eisenhower
rallies freedom's forces in the fight for peace